number four is here beautiful thing on a
scale of one to ten what's the chaos
rating in your house right now well it
is it is bonkers man
i think me and lauren have finally you
know after almost six years of being a
parent i think we just learned to just
embrace the chaos and realize that that
is
that is the season that we're in you
know we got a six-year-old four-year-old
a two-year-old and a five-month-old
[Music]
i hear that you and uh katy perry bonded
over being young parents
what are those conversations like mostly
centered around food every kid that we
have is just like when they hit two
years old it's just like why do you not
want to eat your dinner and i think what
we kind of bonded over was that it's not
really about the food it's about them
finding
their independence
thomas and katie continued to bond over
parenthood while collabing on his sixth
album where we started we shot a music
video the other week and i think the
director was getting kind of mad at us
because every time he'd say cut
we would just dive back into talking
about like parenting strategy and then
we'd shoot another scene dive back into
talking about parenting strategy so we
had it we had a great time though you've
been a fan of katy perry for a very long
time he said since you're like 14 years
old what does your 14 year old self
think about the situation you're in now
just to be working with someone like
that like a just a an icon you know it's
it's kind of like man i'm just honored
that you ever wanted to work with me in
the first place like this is uh this is
very wild for me
[Music]
i gotta say happy early birthday i can't
believe i'm about to be 32 but i'm here
for it what does that feel like
when my wife and i are skiing i feel
like i'm 16
and then on school mornings i feel like
i'm 65.
[Music]